welcome to this video playing Usama
Germany ok that's an important game why
because I'm one 2,300 flat and if I fall
below 2,300 I'm feeling terrible so
let's see that I can avoid that not a
very exciting opening anyway ok you're
shooting for nine th for its not working
at the moment let's prepare d5 here
right edge for this ok I can go here now
for a 4 inch she takes no it's not
working but this is not bad porn hangs
on d3 and d4 as a threat absolutely
winds ever win this game come on we know
2300 feels like wrong ok so i can take
these three now here taking that night
on c4
let's do this c3 is also hanging maybe
just did two it's not yet possible close
but not yet possible let's kick this
away look at five is some kind of weird
move that sometimes have to yeah check
that they don't work okay how to do this
now take and take maybe just that you
yeah he i was thinking i can take here
that's not quite working so let's do
this and just keep the corn light before
ed 42 was nice on to to win oMG to hear
you would have to give the exchange and
i guess no c5 you will take be five
let's not like AI can premiere that can
prepare that
I wanted to step out of 97 this is why
rookie aid it also prepares night see
for now and 94 or just rookie 7 + + 27
I just rendered and that's night see for
coming so what now just taking their
only three or d 2 is also possible just
for the end game I don't know that's
probably easiest 42
rookie to now is there some way for him
to save it okay well anyway I can also
just take where's the where is the plain
white resigns okay so I got got that one
in and we have a pretty normal position
around here I think not sure that ftp is
so great unit it's it's certainly
playable nothing special happening here
but i've out here he has to improve a
little bit at least he has to improve
here and not sure if Queen f2 is good
actually it's that's already quite
awkward that that hangs and deform he
went back we need to know he went here
this is what the engine suggests but
that also leads to a terrible position
for white where he's just sitting on a
weakness and has no play a queen f2 was
already bad the TMP a black essentially
wins with a couple of a couple of good
alternatives along the way but i think
it was good enough probably c5 was
already working in i had the suspicion
but I didn't want to our gate to was
when I missed okay that is quite strong
but it was completely okay just picking
up everything yeah yeah p he played them
the move quick ever quick the move
quickly have too far too quickly after
d5 is already in bad shape I mean he can
go back this is this is maybe the
relatively best option just um play this
for example this is not looking great
with that with those pawns but it's not
so easy for black to exploit White has
roop t1 whoop dee 5 for example the
knight on c6 still misplaced in this
position can get excellent for black if
he gets his pieces somewhat improved the
night for example yeah to d6 and
something like that but that takes a
long while it's not so easily done ok
thanks for watching